there is a victimization complex that is
a human trait it is a way that human
beings can go wrong where you fetishize
victimhood you exaggerate victimhood
because being the victim gives you a
sense of absolution and significance
this race the black american race has
encouraged the od on that
john mcguire welcome to the show
thank you chris
i've been wanting to ask someone this
for quite a while and as a linguist the
tasks fall into you have you looked at
the development of the word woke
over the last few years and where it's
come from and how it's rose to
prominence
yeah it's become pejorative actually and
i've um
actually seen it happening even as
recently as five years ago woke just
meant politically informed in a leftist
way
but
there's been a certain segment of woke
people who have
been so noxious in the public square
especially over the past couple years
that usually now woke is used in
quotation marks to mean that annoying
kind of woke person and so we really
knew term because it doesn't mean what
it meant in say 2015. it's weird how
quickly these things can happen it shows
the power of ridicule i think you saw
that with politically correct for a
while politically correct was the thing
that meant politically correct and then
it got taken by people that objected to
politically correct to use as a
pejorative and now woke has kind of
supplanted that position
it really has i remember when you could
say politically correct and not flinch
it was in the early 80s that i first
heard it and even by 89 90 it had
already fallen down the well and now is
virtually unusable woke was a very handy
replacement because it's good to have a
word to indicate that you are
enlightened in a leftist way but you
know once the fights start then the word
is going to get worn out and and abused
and hurt and then you need a new term
i'll be very interested to see what the
new term is but it's too early to tell
what's work racism then
well racism is that there's a certain
kind of woke person
who feels that um
it's not only about being leftistly
informed but that there's this basic
proposition that we must be primarily
focused on overturning power
differentials and especially what they
call white supremacy that that must be
the focus of intellectual artistic and
moral endeavor
and if you're not doing that then you
are evil and you should be chased out of
the public square you should lose your
job you should be shamed that's a kind
of woke person with that kind of person
they're so committed to this basic
display that they know what racism is
that's it's become the
the heartbeat of a religion very much a
religion
that has become so important that even
when they do things and stick up for
things that hurt black people they don't
pay attention and they don't care
because what they really care about is
showing that they know racism exists
because that shows that they're good
people so it ends up being unintentional
but it is awoke racism and this book has
been written to blow the whistle on it
it seems like there's an inherent
connection with virtue signaling there
if the reason that people are prepared
to take a narrative over the top of its
actual impacts the reason for that is
that they're concerned with how they're
signaling to the world at large
i would even put it as the virtue
signaling has become a religion instead
of just something that people do idly
and it's really scary to see because
people will
fiercely virtue signal and claim that
what they're doing is creating social
justice they're claiming that it's for
other people but they're much less
concerned with the other people than
they really would be if we hadn't gone
from politics to a religion what do you
think is the genesis of this obsession
that we've got with race at the moment
well
it's two things
one
is that um the george floyd murder was
particularly egregious
and it happened and i don't make i don't
want this to sound like people were
being deliberately cynical but it
happened at a time when america was on
lockdown everybody was stuck inside
everybody was lonely and bored and angry
and it was spring and so i think
there was an extent to which people
value the opportunity to go outside to
make some noise to interact with other
people i think if that hadn't happened
during the pandemic it wouldn't have
been at such a fever pitch because
george floyd's death was egregious but
unfortunately we see things like that
regularly in the united states it wasn't
that different but there was that and
then there was also that we have social
media now and so even if there had been
a pandemic i'm trying to be an
experimental social scientist which is
not my job but if there had been a
pandemic 10 years ago and everybody had
been stuck inside and a man had been
killed the way george floyd was i don't
think that all of this would have
happened because there was no twitter
yet or twitter wasn't as influential but
people can communicate and kind of whip
one with one another up with a speed and
a fervor that just technologically
wasn't possible until really over the
past under 15 years so combine the
pandemic and social media and you end up
in this bizarre new moment where
self-involved radicalism is being put
forth as the heartbeat of progressivism
on race and we've got to undo that and
get back to whatever we were doing
before just a racist is america at the
moment
it's kind of racist you know it is um
prescribed to be openly racist to a
degree that i think
we're beginning to forget how
extraordinary it is and the ordinary
educated person examines themselves for
personal racist bias
there are societal inequities where
black people clearly are behind for
reasons that you can't blame on black
people themselves and that's what's
called awkwardly societal racism i don't
like that term but there are racial
inequities in this society that often
are based on racism in the past almost
never racism in the present but they can
be what are called legacies of what
happens what are some examples of those
well so for example if um
black kids
are less likely to embrace school
the reason for it is not that black
people are dumb but it's because in the
past when schools were desegregated
white kids and teachers were so hostile
against the black kids coming in that a
meme developed of thinking of school as
the white man's game that was racism now
that same sentiment got passed along as
just one way of being a cliquish
teenager and today you'll have a black
kid who feels like if i really like
school it's like i'm doing something for
other people not my own people it's a
legacy of racism in the past but it's
not about racism now that really throws
a lot of people some one writer has
called it racism without racists and
that there's very little room for that
in our current discussion all right so
why do you call woke racism or
anti-racism a religion
it is a religion because there's a part
of it that it's allowed to proceed
without addressing logic there's a part
of many religions that entails that you
give up
logical sequential thinking in favor of
suspension of disbelief that's part of
many religions and when it comes to this
modern anti-racism you are supposed to
suspend that disbelief when questions
come up that are inconvenient
to the general paradigm and so for
example if you are a black man in an
underserved community you are in more
danger of being killed
than say i am now if you're going to be
killed the chances that you're killed by
a stray white cop are infinitesimal the
chances that you're going to be killed
by somebody just like you from six
blocks away if you are gonna be killed
are much much much higher
under our debate we scream to the
heavens about the cop
and just pay lip service to the fact
that there's a problem within black
communities themselves and that's
because the religion says you show that
you're aware of racism and so that
automatically makes the stray white cop
interesting and it turns your head away
from the murders being committed in much
greater numbers by people within
underserved communities that's religion
the fact that if you bring that up to
people they get irritated that there's a
belief system that it's in commensurate
with it's religion because frankly
there's no answer it's not that somebody
like me is missing something it's simple
any ten-year-old could figure it out and
yet you're treated and this is why it's
also a religion you're treated as a
heretic for bringing up the question and
pushing it it's a religion because if
you don't agree you're pushed out a
window if it were just an ideology it
would be i don't like how you're talking
about that that's the way it was say 20
years ago today it's if you are against
the way i think you have to leave you
can't work here you shouldn't teach this
course you should go to another town
that's religion because that is exactly
how the fundamentalist christian used to
treat heretics and so the terminology is
different but people who are woke
racists treat people who don't agree
with them as if they were heretics
that's exactly the sentiment and they
behave exactly the way prosecutorial
christians behaved in medieval europe
exactly it's not about physical
punishment but the sentiment is the same
including wanting to deprive people of
their livelihoods
who are the priests or the popes or the
imams of anti-racism
the intelligentsia today it's most of
the professoriate and most of the people
who lead the main
media organs and their views do not just
stay in what's called the acela corridor
here named after a certain train on the
northeast coast it's not just it's not
just them
it ends up percolating into general
society and i find that process in the
clinical sense fascinating how do you
get
from what some woke racist professor at
harvard thinks down to the way people
are having conversations on street
corners and yet it it can happen these
people have major influence yeah it
would be incredible if that was done
purely by designer if someone's able to
work out a way to distribute this
particular message people i mean that's
an incredibly powerful bug to be able to
get into the back of people's brains if
you can limitly hijab jack them in that
way and create an entire new lexicon an
entire new world view around it you
bypass all of culture you bypass facts
and reason
that's powerful
it is and that is how they use social
media in particular twitter is a really
scary thing and i'm on twitter you know
i get it and it can be kind of addictive
but what that thing can do in making us
all a village
is unfortunate and especially so in that
there's nothing that we can do about it
it's not just about the mobs it's the
influence that
disproportionately small number of
people can have on so very many others
but we're stuck with that part so we
just have to put other messages out
there and that's what i'm trying to do
with this this new book i looked at some
stats around this a little while ago and
i think 98
of content on
twitter is produced by two percent
of the users
so you have this huge power law of just
very very vocal loud people on that so
are those is the intelligentsia and the
writers and the academics are they who
you refer to as the elect because that's
what the book was called originally
right cause he did it on your sub stack
that's right i called it the elect and
as often what i title a book doesn't
make it into the final round because i
suck at titles but yeah it's the elect
and it's them it's the it's the media
it's the intelligence but to be honest i
don't call it the elect because those
people happen to have high positions in
society because the elect is also a lot
of humble school teachers and school
principals it's just people out there
who have any kind of influence on the
way people think including what children
are taught and these are people who i
don't think they think of themselves
consciously as having been chosen but
they behave like that kind of person
they think that they're bearing an
invaluable wisdom against which nothing
logical or moral can be said so they
they are priests they don't put it that
way they'll roll their eyes if you say
that but they're priests and they are
parishioners they are a flock and all of
that is great but we don't let religion
run our society and so i think that
these people i don't want to chase these
people off of the planet but they should
retreat to their churches and worship
together and stop shouting down
everybody else who wishes to live in a
secular fashion i've not read
white fragility or how to be anti-racist
please don't
how would you describe those books to me
well white fragility is the second worst
book ever written i mean literally the
in terms of the books that i've
encountered i read one book once when i
was about 20
that was supposedly explaining how
various old hollywood cartoon characters
got their names but the person who wrote
it didn't have any ideas and so it was
things like well daffy duck was probably
called daffy duck because of his daffy
personality i remember back then
thinking this is the worst book i have
ever read now the second worst book i've
ever read was when two summers ago i
read white fragility just a truly
horrific
tome where the idea is that whites need
to sit down in a circle and confront
their complicity in an inherently racist
society and understand that they're
being subtly racist in just about
anything that they do or say and what
you're supposed to do once you go from
there is not clear and
and d'angelo even says
to be hastily thinking about solutions
like what are we going to do in society
where do we go from here that's wrong
you're supposed to quote unquote do the
work of identifying the racism within
you and she's very careful about saying
she's not trying to be hostile she's
saying that you can't help being racist
in this society she's not condemning but
still the question is what in the world
would all of this zen-like
self-discipline do for poor black people
who actually need help and you can tell
that she
doesn't give a good god damn and when
asked what she thinks of black people
who don't agree with her she basically
calls us uncle toms so that's that's all
there is and then with um kendy
one doesn't want to go too far into
his work and i avoided doing so too much
until about a year ago when he started
calling me out but
kendy is somebody who thinks in binaries
he's not reflective he thinks in you
know binary oppositions he's
his stuff reminds me of book reports
essentially and his idea is that if
you're not being actively anti-racist
then you qualify as racist no i don't
even know what that means but that's the
way he writes and he is the um
he's the kind of black person who grew
up actually thinking of white people as
devils that's a black nationalist kind
of perspective and he studiously makes
sure to let you know that he's let go of
it now but that way of looking at things
informs the way he sniffs the world and
you can listen to his talks and see that
he really does think that we live in
this country that is stamped from the
beginning with racism and all about
racism now and he comes up with these
prescriptions for what should be done in
this country that quite simply are those
of
someone who does not know much about how
modern societies work and has never had
to think about it and i didn't talk this
way about him for a good couple years
because i'm not inherently mean but he's
been so nasty to me and he started it
that i've decided okay i'm gonna have to
be honest he's not 25 he's old enough to
take it and so really kendy is somebody
who was working humbly doing his best
and he was abruptly thrust into the
spotlight two summers ago and he's doing
his best but i
am baffled as to what sort of leadership
he's gonna propose because he doesn't
think subtly that's it so those are
those are the two people and i don't
you know um they have sold a great many
books and gotten very rich and that's
fine with me but the thing is if you
read the two of those books it's very
hard to see how they fit into
america as it actually is as opposed to
this
1950 that robin d'angelo thinks we've
never gotten past
or practically the 1850 that kendy seems
to almost wish we were still in because
his dichotomies would apply more
gracefully so yeah they're both um i
frankly consider both books utterly
worthless um candies i wouldn't put on
this worst book ever list i just think
that there's not a whole lot of there
there deangelo's book as i've said
elsewhere should be used as furniture
it's a really it's a nice size for if
you've got a wobbly table you could put
that book under and your table would be
solid truly terrible piece of work but
apparently some people disagree with me
is there a sense that these people
would be afraid to admit victory
that if they were to achieve some sort
of equality they're basically putting
themselves out of a job
yeah um i wouldn't put it that way it's
not that they're thinking i wouldn't
have a job
if any if they had to admit that things
were not the way they say it would
deprive them of purpose essentially i'm
sure that both both of those people and
people like them at this point could
retire they never have to work again
it's not about having a livelihood and i
don't sense that for example with either
d'angelo or candy that they especially
like attention
looking at themselves on tv i don't
think that's either one of them but if
they had to admit that america is not
the way they depict it they wouldn't
have anything to do you know all of us
as somebody told me when i was first
starting out we all have a few arrows in
our quiver essentially there's a few
things that we do and say and if you
can't use them what else are you going
to do and you know robin d'angelo's in
her 60s for example kendy is pushing 40
you can't completely
reform yourself after a certain point
and nobody wants that and i think just
in general you you have a sense of your
purpose on this earth well if the job is
already done
what are you going to do in your spare
time i can understand why they can't let
it go but that means that there have to
be voices speaking directly
against people like that when they're
less correct and less useful than many
people are being told
how does anti-racism harm black people
then
in many ways so for example all of the
effort that we are devoting to
quote-unquote defunding and reforming
the police
all
at least 70 percent of that effort
should be going into
solving cases of homicide within black
communities to giving really special
attention to the to the organizations in
those communities that are working to
defuse violence it ought to be a
national marshall plan and so you harm
black people by focusing instead on the
occasional stray white cop you harm
black people if
you see that black boys commit more
violence in public schools than any
other boys and that they therefore get
suspended more which is true
and you see that and instead you say
that the only reason they're getting
suspended more is because of bias
despite the fact that the data does not
support that at all
and therefore you see schools starting
to be more lenient with violent black
boys and therefore the other
black kids in the schools get beat up
more and their grades go down all of
which is documented and you watch all of
that happening and still keep on
enjoying that you can use three b's in a
row by saying the bigotry against black
boys and you can get a certain kind of
crowd to applaud
the way that debate is is conducted
is racist because you're basically
making it so that black kids get beat up
more while you call yourself anti-racist
by saying that there must be bigotry
against black boys and people clap
that's racist behavior and the book goes
on and on in that vein i would say that
the chapter on that is the longest one
because i wrote woke racism not to make
somebody like sean hannity clap it is
not written for the fox news crowd and i
didn't write it just to describe the
birth of a new religion the description
of that i've done that in a couple of
articles that it was boring to write
that part i've said that what i want to
write is that this new religion
is harmful it's not just that it's
excessive i'm not asking people to try
to understand each other because i don't
think the elect are subject to any kind
of constructive discussion i'm saying
that to let these people do what they do
is racism in itself i don't think that
people realize that because they're so
afraid of these people but that those
are the stakes here
why is this world view so popular then
if if people are afraid and it really
does feel like it's quite detached from
reality
why is the worldview so popular
yeah
if you're white it feels good to have
something all figured out if you're
white and you're not religious it feels
good to have another one
if you're white it feels really good to
show that you're not racist i can very
much imagine being a white person and
feeling it very important to show that
for example it's very important to me to
show that i'm not sexist yeah the last
thing i want is for somebody to call me
a male chauvinist and i would say that
there's a bit of me that sometimes even
puts blinders on as to why what might be
the occasional inconvenient truth i just
want to show that i am not a sexist
because frankly i'm scared i can tell
that's the way white people feel about
the race issue and then if you are a
black person
to frame yourself as an eternal victim
gives you a sense of belonging it gives
you a sense of significance if you're
lacking a sense of it for some other
reason it's no surprise that a lot of
black people feel insecure to an extent
because of the history of the race if
you are a noble victim which is the only
possible if you're not one you can't
wallow in victimhood if you really are
suffering from day to day but once
you're okay to frame yourself as a
victim in some abstract way feels good
it's a cloak and i completely understand
people you know taking that cloak and
wearing it there is a victimization
complex that is a human
trait it is a way that human beings can
go wrong where you you fetishize
victimhood you exaggerate victimhood
because being the victim gives you a
sense of absolution
and significance
this race the black american race has
encouraged the od on that so combined
white people looking to show that
they're not racist and black people who
build an identity not all black people
but enough who build an identity around
their
depiction of themselves as victims that
doesn't really fit modern society and
you've got this new religion where
terrible things end up happening for
reasons that can't be coherently
defended
at the end of the day
if it negatively affects black people
and black communities you would imagine
that after a while there would have to
be pushback i know that some of the
statistics to do with police with
murders in inner cities is directly
correlated with how many police are on
the streets and i remember reading an
article and they said this may be an
uncomfortable statistic but it seems
like the best way to reduce homicides is
to put police back on the streets and
you think well
i i don't understand why it's
uncomfortable if if someone has made a
hypothesis
that
getting rid of the police will make the
streets safer and that turns out to be
wrong there's nothing uncomfortable
about it it's only uncomfortable for the
people that had attached their sense of
well-being and ideology and self
to the outcome of this it's just a it's
just wrong
yep
and a critical mass of the people who
argue for this quote unquote defunding
of the police don't live in those
neighborhoods and i want to give props
to the ones who do there's a certain
kind of person who talks that way who
does live in neighborhoods where they
listen to cop cars and you know they
they know that people have been killed
not too terribly far away but even with
those people the ideology reigns and so
they'll say something like well it's not
like we need no cops but the ideology
means that they have to be anti-cop and
that's the problem ideology can be a
really dangerous thing when it comes to
people
in body bags and it also there's a
condescension involved where you've got
this woke person and this could be a
white one or a black one or a latina or
an asian one who thinks that the police
need to be reined in the police need to
be defunded
and then you have say the black
grandmother who has watched legions of
kids being killed by other kids who she
knows saying no i want more police and
nobody disrespects that woman to her
face but she's generally thought of as
somebody who doesn't know what's good
for her she doesn't understand the
larger picture and if the larger picture
is just that we're sad about george
floyd something that happened one night
in minnesota to one man and we're not
going to look at the larger picture
that's religion and so it means that
that grandmother is probably a devout
christian that woke college professor is
a devout elect he's even more religious
than her but he doesn't know it
it really does feel like anti-racism
treats black people like simpletons and
cretins like that's how it feels it
feels like they say look no no no no you
don't need to worry about what's good
for you
we know
we know what's good for you just put
your faith in us
that yep and [ __ ] isn't used as much
in american english and so i don't put
it that way but i wish it were because
yeah
anti-racism treats black people like
dum-dums and yet you see so many black
people including the very smartest ones
just lapping it up because the
victimhood complex is a powerful
attractant to all human beings we all
know professional martyrs it's human and
so
once you've settled into that and that's
your comfort zone you will accept any
amount of condescension as long as you
can consider to think of yourself as a
perpetual victim it's a nasty social
cocktail
do you have any idea about how much
credit are you enjoying the use of
credit just anglicize everything for the
rest of the day talk about cups of tea
and stuff fish and chips um all right
governor uh
have you got any idea about how the
black community's views on racism and
anti-racism are split i'm aware the
black community is not some person that
we can just go and speak to it's not an
individual mass that we can survey but
you have any ideas around this
i do
if you survey the black community as in
people who have phds and write for the
major media organs
you would get the impression that the
black view except for the occasional
weirdo like me
is that racism in our era is largely
unchanged since 1960 it's just that
people are more polite and they've been
you know the dec the deck chairs have
been rearranged on the titanic you would
think that is the way everybody thinks
the minute you go out into the real
world you find that it's different i
know that from my own family i know that
from listening to people on the subway
in new york which is a great way to get
a sense of the real world you know we
don't drive here we sit on the train and
most of the people on the train do not
have the salary or the the circumstances
of somebody like me and you just listen
and you find that the actual view of the
community many intelligentsia understand
there's a certain social conservatism
among ordinary black people but i don't
think they fully understand that
ordinary black people are not not nearly
as subject to this victimization complex
as
educated people are the professional
victim at say the black barber shop
that's one or two people that's a type
and often it's somebody who's
self-educated and has read a lot of the
things that people in the media in the
university right the bookish person who
maybe didn't go to college but you know
reads
that's where you get that sort of thing
then there's kind of a street corner
element
certain religious figures certain
churches but that's not the default i
remember um it's almost like somebody
wrote this for me it was like but i know
they weren't performing for me there was
a black couple who were sitting next to
me on the train i think they had a child
together and there was a sign on the new
york subway for a while where they
showed five different authors
um most of them of color and i forget
why but it was advertising five books
and it was some sort of initiative from
a library or something like that all
five of the books were very much the
ones that today's intelligentsia
argue are the good ones about race like
one of them was tanahasi coates book um
between the world and me and four others
that were kind of like that and they had
other authors holding them up
enthusiastically as if these books
needed advertisement it was a rather
insufferable sign but it was just there
for about six months and i remember
listening to this this couple and the
woman just said rocking the carriage i
get the feeling she wasn't college
educated and she said
dem is all lib did she say damn
no she said those are all liberal books
and she had this frown on her face and i
don't think her husband quite got it but
she said those are all liberal books how
come they can't have different kinds
even she got it that this would there's
a bias in this sign as if the only
relevant black books are the ones that
say that the world is going to hell i
don't think she was that unique but you
would never know she existed based on
the sorts of people were talking about
this is an intelligentsia issue for the
most part she needs to get on twitter if
you got on twitter everyone would know
about her opinion we should find i
almost wanted to say who are you but i
didn't want to sign you up for a twitter
account because i will do that
what do you think about the uh about the
concept of whiteness
i don't know what the purpose of it is
and so yeah they're there there's some
white people and there is um
there is disproportionate power
there is a sense of entitlement that a
certain kind of white person has a
certain naivete
sure that's there from the world
historical perspective
white people these northern and western
european people have had a
disproportionate and in many ways
grievous impact upon the world certainly
the question is whether here in 2021
with all those things having happened
the solution to that is some grand
revolution in our psychosocial
consciousness right now is that really
what we need or
can we have a more meat and potatoes
aspect to things and help people who
need help live in the society which for
better or for worse these white people
largely created when they started
getting in ships and sailing across the
ocean
and i think for a lot of people there's
a sense that somehow there needs to be
some reckoning i wonder if they wish we
would all go back to living in bands of
two or three hundred people by the sides
of the river i mean that seems to be
what they want
unfortunately modernity developed
through the actions and machinations and
ravagings and rapings and pillagings of
a certain kind of white person
advantaged by the geography of a
peninsula called europe that happened
but here we are now and there's so many
things that we have to do so i think
that yeah there is a such thing as
whiteness but the question is whether we
need to de-center it to the way that
we're talking about and to the to the
degree that people are talking about
decentering whiteness and if we
completely de-center whiteness the
question is what have we got and is that
really a world that we want maybe we
just need to go back to the way we were
thinking about these things about 20
years ago where the idea was everything
white is not good a great many things
that are not white or good and let's
make sure that we pay as much attention
as we can to everything that isn't white
because whiteness is not all that's good
the new idea that you decenter whiteness
and stigmatize it and pretend for
example that music theory is white
that's kabuki
or perhaps with more respect that's
religious fervor that's not making sense
of things or turning up on time or the
nuclear family or grit and determination
or precision right yeah yeah like those
things
that to me was one of the most
disturbing things to see
especially when it got demonized uh to
as something that the black community
shouldn't aspire to
as values which no one should aspire to
and that the solution for is not to play
the game well but to rearrange the rules
of the game so that people who don't
play that game well can play it badly
and still win
that to me
is so pernicious it's like
turning up on time
for a thing
is required throughout the rest of your
life whether that's a doctor but you've
got a doctor's appointment you have an
important surgery and you rock up two
hours late and the surgeon's on to
somebody else and you want to complain
about the fact that that's structurally
whiteness and i don't adhere to your
concept of what being on time is
or rules when you look when you roll the
clock forward to do with levels of
poverty black boys and black girls
growing up without a father in the
family like nuclear family it's one of
the core central supporting structures
that having a good childhood that forms
a robust and effective adulthood is
built on top of it actually feels to me
like
the sort of thing that you would slip
below the surface if you wanted to make
black people fail
yep
all of that stuff sounds like something
some white supremacist in 1895
would come up with and promulgate and
then we could look back at that person
now and talk about what a monster they
were on yet here's all this stuff i
think that once the religion comes into
it also in that
what you're saying is clearly not an
opinion that's just logic anybody
understands that the idea that to be
precise is white
the only thing you can get out of that
whole idea
that precision
that making deductions and inductions
thinking about results etc that all of
this is white
is roughly that black people are
supposed to just i swear this is what
people are thinking black people are
supposed to jam
and dance
and have raggedy conversations where we
intuit one another's feelings
and reason
that's frankly that's what it sounds
like like what are we gonna do dance you
know if we're not going to do real
physics i think we're supposed to just
dance and once again that sounds like
you do dunks better than white people
though
that frankly that is true and i think a
lot of them are thinking that you know
they don't move as well no so we're
going to do what we do which is jam but
jamming wouldn't have created the world
that we sit here saying those things in
and you know getting listened to so it's
just
none of it makes sense and that's why
i'm saying that all of this is a creed
rather than something anybody's thought
out it's this expansion of the term
whiteness and white supremacy so dave
chappelle
got called a white supremacist the other
day
because of his comments on gender like
how do you square that circle
well the idea is that there are white
people and then there's everybody else
and everybody else is dealing in
intersectional fashion with oppression
and denigration and not being seen at
the hands of whites if you take on
a perspective of
of antipathy towards one of those groups
underneath and even if you belong to one
of those groups you become
in c2 um that's a misuse of that
expression so just scrap it you become
an honorary white person that's what's
going on so dave chappelle
you know with that rangy black english
and it used to be he's standing there
smoking and you know the one of the
blackest men on the planet because of
those things that he's saying about
trans people he becomes a white
supremacist all of that is
play acting everybody knows that doesn't
make any sense and you know he's had a
very black adulthood a very
black-oriented career where he left his
tv show because he was worried about
what it was making white people think
and yet now he's a white supremacist
because he's not on board with the way
everybody thinks about gay people and
trans people and of course is anybody
surprised listening to his whole career
so that's a lot of this is more of that
so now he's becoming a heretic even
though he's black himself and is fully
quote unquote woke because you have to
make him a heretic because you were part
of a religion where it's your job to put
up your fingers like this at people who
say the wrong thing
this won't do
what do you think about cultural
appropriation
i think the concern over that is absurd
i think cultural appropriation is
inappropriate if somebody from on high
ate somebody from below and makes money
off of it that they didn't what's up
that
there's for example if you say that
elvis presley took on the rock and roll
inflections and music and moves and
became a billionaire while the black men
who originated all of that did not have
as much success and some of them labored
in obscurity i can see an argument that
that's cultural appropriation but the
idea that it's cultural appropriation
when white people do things that anybody
else does
as opposed to anybody else who do things
white people do and that's considered
okay that is as if people are looking
for a reason to be angry as if imitation
isn't a form of flattery as if people
living in proximity aren't going to
imitate one another to a certain extent
and as if any of us wouldn't want
america's popular music since about
1890. if cultural appropriation is wrong
there's no ragtime there's no jazz there
are no show tunes there's no rock and
roll there's no porky and bess there's
no nothing yeah basically our music no
offense but like i don't think this
isn't an insult for your country but our
music here would be euro pop we would
have that shitty music that you hear if
you go to a dance club in finland that
would be what it except the music from
america and yet we're supposed to call
all of this cultural appropriation and
do high fives because the religion is
all about identifying racism it doesn't
make any sense but we end up having
these fruitless debates over it because
of the imperatives of this religion yeah
the power dynamics and punching up
versus punching down when it comes to
cultural appropriation really just
doesn't seem to make sense to me i
remember last year right in the thick of
it it might mean this year uh when it
was st patrick's day on the 17th of
march
and someone had highlighted that there's
a potential hypocrisy here that people
are allowed to wear the hats and say
good morning to you and like
pots of gold and stuff like that and
everyone's got a ginger beard on how is
that not cultural appropriation and i
remember this brand tweeted out saying
that's not appropriation it's
appreciation i thought
like this is just lexical brazilian jiu
jitsu here
yes
it is and what it really is supposed to
be about is brown people for the most
part
having a reason to feel aggrieved
and as we've said before they're reasons
why white people would pretend to buy
into it they're reasons why brown people
will pretend to buy into this you're
appropriating me whereas you can see
cultural mixture in so many places such
as you know this pot of gold business
and you can think if that's okay
why not okay for a white person to say
you to man what's the difference who
does it hurt you know it's not as if if
a white person imitates black people
it's taking away
from us you know you took our word
people say but if we keep using it
that's fine and there are 99 other words
that black people use that white people
never pick up what are the contours of
this argument but it's all just for that
purpose of the genuflection
what is
what are some of the ways that we can
lessen this grip on culture then because
it does feel to use the brazilian
jiu-jitsu analogy again it does feel
like a
it's locked in pretty tight
it is but i'm not sure how tight and i
think that something really went wrong
in about june of 2020 which is when i
started writing that book in in fury
and social media really did focus some
things but i think there's a backlash
now i think that a lot of that moment
had to do with the fact that people were
locked up inside and whipped up by the
chat function on zoom
into
some opinions that were overblown
some decisions to fire people which
wouldn't have happened in a room where
people could actually breathe each
other's air and see each other's facial
expressions i think a lot of it was that
and so you just need there to be a
pushback and i'm trying to be part of
that i think in the conversation we're
seeing an amount of pushback against
this way of looking at things that we
weren't seeing a year ago because i
think a critical mass of people in
america i think the majority of thinking
people in america see that this is wrong
the issue is just creating a bit of a
backbone in people so the people will be
willing
to be called a racist in the public
sphere and not think of their lives as
being over social media creates a space
where we have to get used to
being mobbed sometimes being roasted to
an acrid kind of dialogue and that
includes being called things i find
myself thinking of i don't spend as much
time on twitter as many people like me
but that doesn't mean i don't look at it
several times a day and i've noticed
that
you you go on there and you'll they'll
be a kind of person who writes you
something really really nasty you know
go the [ __ ] to hell or you know i your
career has disappointed me etc and i've
noticed that with that person who's the
meanest
you get used to mean but that person
who's just like a bad out of hell
they inevitably
inevitably that person has six
six followers it's always some lone wolf
and i don't know if it's a troll i don't
know if it's somebody who doesn't bathe
and is just sitting there in their chair
i get the feeling those people are
perfectly normal executives but the
people who are that mean don't have any
friends and i always think of that as
kind of an analogy the people who are
defenestrating people for saying things
like reverse racism etc it's a very
vocal minority of people who've been
been caught up in something most of us
are just watching those people and the
reason they get away with this stuff is
because we're scared we don't want to
get that tweet from them you know that
tweet that i get from the occasional
person that person's almost always male
you know it's a type well you know that
person says it and who cares you know i
don't hear from that person again i'm
certainly not going to write to them in
the same way this sort of mob
we just have to start letting people say
you're a white supremacist and just take
a deep breath have some bourbon
let it pass after about a couple weeks
if you don't respond to those people
often they just walk away now some
people are going to be in more of a
position to deal with people like that
than others but we have to make a
climate where people with elect
viewpoints
are not able to labor under the illusion
that their views are truth and that
everybody's just gonna bow down they
think everybody's bowing down because
that we realize we're racists and we're
just listening we will never get through
to people like that but we just need
them to sit down they used to be sitting
at the table it's not that people who
believe in critical race theory had
never been heard from until a year and a
half ago it's that they used to be
seated at the table with the rest of us
the elect need to sit down they don't
need to leave the room we need to hear
from people on the hard left all the
time they have interesting things to say
but we need them to sit the hell down
and the only way that's going to happen
is we have to stop being so afraid of
the rhetoric that they spout when you go
afoul of their religious tenets we can't
let them win and i think that at this
point america is still
so unaccustomed to that kind of person
having so much of a presence that we're
getting a sense of how to deal with them
and i know it's happening that in canada
australia and the uk as well what do you
do with that kind of person what you do
is you tell them to sit down and you
don't rest and you don't look out of
their eyes until they do and if we don't
learn how to do that then we're going to
be run by prelates we're going to be
we're going to have our lives run by
anti-intellectual priests who have no
genuine concern with the well-being of
the people they claim to speak for
that's not the way this is supposed to
go and i think we all know it we just
have to we have to
frankly grow a pair so to speak
even if you're not in ibrahmex candy or
a john mcwhorter or whatever somebody
who is online with a big following that
can cause
swaths that's a traffic weapon that can
just direct people around the internet
there is a role i think that everyone
else can play which is to
observe the compulsion inside of
themselves to be a part of a cancel mob
to pile on someone on twitter because
you think
this is this tweet's got calling someone
else got 10 000 likes i i need to reply
to this because it's a virtue signal and
to just think well hang on a second a
lot of the time there's wisdom in the
individual and madness in a crowd so
should i actually look at this group
behavior as a signal that there's
something behind this or that there's a
signal that there's something not behind
this is this mass hysteria or is this
mass accuracy
and exactly yeah i think that's accuracy
because it very rarely is uh final thing
talk to me about watching the lexical
change from black lives matter
to that now being bifurcated into black
lives matter and blm when people refer
to it because that was fascinating for
me to watch
you know to be honest chris i've never
thought about that as a particular
transition but um blm shows that black
lives matter has
drilled itself into the general
consciousness to the extent that it's no
longer about the words and their meaning
it's a sentiment it is a it's a position
blm becomes one of the the markers the
shibboleths of whether you have the
right kind of thought and i don't think
black lives matter is wrong in itself i
wish there was something as powerful
with a cute acronym that was about
fixing black on black homicide as well
but i guess i'm wrong to call call it
black on black homicide that's a whole
other rant that people have but blm now
is a way of essentially almost you know
mumbling as you go past somebody in a
prison yard you know some sort of code
to make it clear that you're on the same
side black lives matter also was awkward
because theoretically it would have been
more useful to call it black lives
matter too because that's what was meant
it didn't mean only black lives matter
but a lot of people on the right
pretended not to understand that and
started saying no
white lives matter too and black lives
matter too wouldn't have been as catchy
as slogan you wanted to be three things
but it being called blm shows how much
this has gotten down into the
consciousness it's all over
windows it's drawn on streets businesses
that have nothing to do with politics
will have blm in their window that is an
interesting development but some of it
means i'm not racist it means i'm a good
person
don't call me names on twitter and the
problem is what kind of ideology are you
espousing you're defending yourself
against being called racist but a lot of
the people who would mock you is okay
are also people who think that it's kind
of cute when black people riot through
an inner city and then go into the
downtown of a city and that some of the
black people in question start breaking
things and stealing things which has
nothing to do with making a statement
about say defunding the police and all
of that is okay because we have this
apocalyptic vision where we're going to
burn the mother down we're going to just
burn down the master's house and so
that's what it is when you break into a
best buy and steal a tv because george
floyd died no that's not progressive but
we're not supposed to talk about it
because the religion isn't compatible
with treating it for what it is
so i brought that up with someone
yesterday i had david pakman on the show
who's a very well reasoned left as far
as i can see very well reasoned left
leaning commentator and i referred to
the blm riots from last year and
immediately he pulled me up on it and
said the blm riots
i've never heard it called that i
thought you've never heard
the
incidents that we saw last year with
shops being burnt like if you were to
look up riot in a dictionary it would be
for me things on fire brick through
windows and stuff being stolen like that
those are the three horsemen of the riot
apocalypse and that was what we saw um
so i can't tell
i it would very much surprise me if that
was actually the case that he hadn't
ever heard that before um
but yeah that really shocked me and it
seemed to shock him that i used that
term so more than anything what that
taught me was we exist
two content creators that move in
similar spaces david's shows bigger than
mine but still
that we can see completely different
worlds
which is crazy very much so uh and very
much so the thing about blm that i
thought was interesting was what you see
now is people referring to the movement
itself and the organization sorry you
see people referring to the organization
as blm but the movement as black lives
matter and i think that what we're
seeing with that is people using blm to
distance themselves from things like the
founder buying a 15 million home in the
whitest neighborhood like just
gentrifying themselves into into
oblivion and blm perhaps as a
organization
has
found itself to be
wanting failing toxic associated with a
bunch of other things that people can no
longer use that so they've actually had
to split that term into two now you have
black lives matter which is the
fundamental principles that undergird
that movement and you have blm the
organization but i don't agree with the
way that their founder got caught with
his son dude correct correct correct i
hadn't been aware of that lexical
bifurcation i'll be on the lookout for
that
now that's that's useful and interesting
yeah i like it john mcguire ladies and
gentlemen woke racism will be linked in
the show notes below and if people want
to keep up to date with everything else
that you do where should they go
well i do a podcast about language not
about race and language especially but
just you know hardcore linguistic-y
stuff but made fun and that's called
lexicon valley and it's at
booksmartstudios.org
used to be at slate but now it's at
bookstartstudios.booksmartstudios.com
and i write a an essay for the times
twice a week i don't know why i signed
up for this but i do that for the new
york times twice a week now so you can
find my hot takes there
and um we'll see what happens after that
i love it thanks john
thank you chris what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace